first a big broad question to start is
Oppenheimer the most challenging feature
you've ever had to edit and if so what
was number two wow um no definitely not
I would say tenant was probably one of
the most challenging ones just the
action yeah just the action in I'm a
comfor Zone um number
two maybe hereditary just cuz it was
kind of um I was just nervous cuz I'd
never done that kind of genre it was
kind of me entering into kind of a genre
thing even though it wasn't genre in the
end I think but
um yeah did that leave you with the itch
to edit more horror movies no definitely
not I think what was so great working
with Ari is that you know he didn't want
it he didn't want a horror editor so he
was he definitely put me at ease with
that but I still felt some sort of
pressure but it was great my brain is
being flooded right now with so many key
moments in that movie where like the
shock value largely comes from the edit
hitting at the perfect point like I
can't imagine sitting there watching
something and watching it over and over
and
over so let's talk a little bit about
Chris Nolan you've worked with a number
of very incredible directors you just
brought up Ari do you notice any shared
traits among the directing greats but
then also can you pinpoint something
about the process of collaborating with
uh Christopher Nolan that is one of a
kind and unique to him wow um yeah uh I
think I have gotten the chance to work
with a lot of writer directors um that's
been kind of a theme uh for me and I
think um it kind of happened that way
but now I pursue it because I quite like
it um so that's a common trait and
obviously writer directors are very
passionate they have that kind of autor
thing um I just find it really engaging
and exciting um and then Chris obviously
is they're all
different um the what was the question
of like what makes something something
that makes the process of collaborating
with him one of a kind one of a kind um
I think what's so great about
collaborating with him and what makes it
special is um that there's both kind of
this driving force of schedule and time
and he's so I mean he obviously he's
been doing it for so long and he does it
so excellently that it's just you know
it's so fine-tuned but there's also this
kind of
relaxed Vibe as well which is such an
interesting thing that I never would
have um how does he do that need that in
my own life I don't know I really don't
know how he does it but it is incredible
like we have such a specific schedule we
have all these like mini deadlines and
things like that but like in between all
of those I feel like we have all the
time in the world to kind of play around
and relax and it kind of it's such a
weird trick I don't know how he does
it's like a weird magic trick speaking
of playing around I I know he's a very
specific uh director and he writes a lot
because he knows what's ultimately going
to work in the edit so where does the
playing around come into play in in that
process is there any particular scene
where you thought you know the creative
possibilities were like wider than
others I think what's so great about him
is yeah his scripts are like a blueprint
they're so fine-tuned and he's um with
the way he writes you know by the time I
read it there's very little editing to
be done and um it's so specific but
what's fun about that is again it's kind
of what I was saying before it's like
it's so structured but then he is so
open to ideas of the ways we can make it
interesting and use editing to make it
interesting within that structure so it
both feel is incredibly structured and
Incredibly creative and yeah again weird
magic trick I don't understand do you
have a specific example of that
something where you know what he had on
the page would have worked but because
you have that editor's eye and insight
you were able to make it more
interesting via that um I don't know
about like more interesting um because
it's such a collaboration I I don't
think there's something I would be like
well I did this because it just that's
not in my nature and that's not kind of
how I see my job you're such a good
collaborator um but I think yeah I think
what's so fun about about for example
the can you hear the music montage we
worked on that constantly like over and
over again but in this way that was fun
like we would work on it and then we
would both be like let's move on and
we'll come back to it and we kept doing
that and we kept screening we both kind
of knew it wasn't there but we weren't
being hard on ourselves or it and then
one kind of Saturday afternoon we really
just like played around and kind of had
these ideas and really mixed it up and
totally did something different and it
was great so I think yeah on the page it
was very specific but I think um with
even down to some images but I think he
was fine to just try different images we
had and just capture the essence of what
he wanted but he was open to kind of
totally playing around with it
constantly that is an exceptional
sequence between between your editing
and also the score and that's the
particular track I can't stop listening
to oh my go it's one of the most
incredible pieces of music and Ludwig
did such a fabulous job his wife Serena
who plays the violin a lot of the time
and I mean um and helped kind of guide
the um players to be able to do
something like that live it was
incredible this is the perfect example
of a movie where everyone's delivering
Peak work and then it's just like
magically all comes together in a way
that uplifts every Department's work
it's like really like the dream scenario
with a film it's it was such a dream um
Team I have to say I love everybody
everyone's so collab we all know each
other which is rare you know because I
work obviously in editing and everyone
certain people just work on set but we
all kind of yeah cross paths and it's
what a great team and then there's also
a bunch of people on your team like
we're going to be we're going to be
seeing a lot of people that are
participating in this press day I have a
good feeling we're going to be seeing a
lot of you in the coming months but what
about your team specifically is there
anyone that you would maybe say is an
unsung hero where you know what they
contributed is absolutely pivotal and
you just want to make sure more people
out there know that person's name and
contribution to the film G it can't just
be one I know I know because my team is
um it's quite a team and they all do
such different specific things and I
mean my uh first assistant Mike f was
incredible the post producer Tina
Anderson is incredible which is what
they do with the film department and the
whole team Tom the negative cutter um or
he you know he cut you know the he cut
the film as we were screening it there's
also a negative cutter from Paris
there's there's too many people to name
but everyone has their specific thing
and everyone did it with such Grace and
what a and such a great attitude which I
was really impressed by here's another
unfair question soz I'm going to ask you
to pick a favorite in a sense going into
editing the film is there any particular
character you were most excited to edit
for but then ultimately is there another
character that caught you by surprise in
terms of like how creatively fulfilling
it was to cut their scenes yeah I mean I
think obviously going into it like
Killian's performance is just like
unbelievable it's just you can't even
get over it and and constantly during
the editing process both me and Chris
would just be wowed by all the things
that he did that we didn't even see and
sometimes would come out but it was just
incredible but one of my favorite
characters over time and I didn't
necessarily think it when I I was
reading the script but I just found such
depth and kind of sadness and
relatability with straws which is Robert
Downey J's character I quite love him
and I find that scene at the end where
he kind of like hits his leg and he asks
like who are the hold outs and he has I
just want to cry like I actually feel
really emotional for him and um I don't
see him as the villain necessarily even
though I know it's easy to see him that
way but I just had a real I developed a
huge soft spot and it and that I'm sure
speaks to uh Robert D J's performance
but yeah speaks to his performance and
writing the idea of him not feeling like
a villain because he feels like a full
living breathing person a fallible
person but he also kind of has to feel
like a villain for a lot of the movie
too so it's like it's just such
brilliant writing directing yeah acting
I just really fell for his character
here is a very very specific question
but sometimes when I sit down and I just
like edit little things for fun when I
hit the perfect cut I just like I get
chills and then every time I watch that
piece back I look forward to that moment
do you have that moment in this
three-hour film oh my God
one cut one cut that like gives you
chills every time it comes back up
chills oh my God one cut I probably
could give you an answer but I'd have to
think about it because it's been a while
since I've even seen the movie and
working on it fair enough yeah what
about going forward now is there a new
tool in your editing tool kit so to
speak that you know you can credit to
Oppenheimer that you are eager to put to
use on a future project
hm I don't know if there's a tool but
one of the interesting things that
happen on this film is I was on another
previous film wakana forever and I came
on late to this movie which typically
editors I think don't like that we like
to be there from the beginning of the
first day of shooting so we can you know
cut as they go and it's kind of
overwhelming to come in I came in a week
or so right after they wrapped and then
you up all the footage which can be
overwhelming and I asked a couple people
who had done it before and everyone was
like don't do it or if you have to do it
get ready but I actually found a way to
approach it and use it to my advantage
and um it was a good lesson for me and a
tool in my toolbox of like okay like I
can use difficult weird situations to my
advantage and figure out a good way to
work around it fresh set of eyes too
it's kind of nice exactly it was kind of
nice to like not be there and not know
anything for once I mean I don't think
that's always the case but I figured out
a way that I could make make it work how
you say you don't like editing action
you got tenet you got of forever you got
certain sequen in this something else
congratulations thank you so much this
was great
I